las alarmas antiaéreas no dejaron de
sonar en Ucrania en víspera de año nuevo
en kiev una oleada de misiles rusos dejó
al menos un muerto y daños materiales en
zonas residenciales interrumpiendo los
tímidos festejos para despedir el año de
la invasión mi esposo y yo literalmente
fuimos arrojados al pasillo recuperamos
la conciencia en el pasillo escuchamos
cristales rompiéndose y luego hubo una
explosión una tras otra la capital no
fue la única ciudad blanco de la
veintena de misiles rusos de los cuales
las fuerzas ucranianas aseguraron haber
derribado 12 en las sureñas Nicolás y
saporilla varias explosiones dejaron
heridos y afectaron edificios Ucrania
denuncia que estos ataques iban
dirigidos contra civiles llevaron a cabo
tales ataques en semana santa en navidad
en año nuevo se llaman a sí mismos
cristianos están muy orgullosos de su
ortodoxia pero están siguiendo al [__]
cerca de la frontera ucraniana en el
lado ruso el presidente Vladimir Putin
se reunió en la base militar de rostov
del Don y brindó con militares para
celebrar el año nuevo
Rusia ha sido empujada a esa línea por
regala todo o pelea pero mientras haya
personas como ustedes hombres y mujeres
que estén a su lado por supuesto no
podemos regalar nada debemos luchar
debemos seguir adelante
también condecoró al general sergeiking
jefe de la operación militar en Ucrania
más temprano en Moscú el ministro de
defensa de Rusia dio un mensaje de año
nuevo triunfalista
nuestra Victoria como el año nuevo es
inevitable
culmina el medio de bombardeos el año
más difícil para Ucrania y sin
posibilidades de paz a la vista el 2023
llegará con nuevas sanciones económicas
de Estados Unidos a Rusia y millonarias
ayudas militares de Washington a kiev